we jump into the modern age of World
Championships we say the modern age as
though you know the Rhine thousand was
the ancient history right it was ancient
history but now we talk about the World
Championship with and on first of all
showing how great a champion he is
holding a title down winning it under
various formats exactly which nobody
else has ever done right if it's a feat
a knockout of its matches candidates you
name it
anon has proven that he is a true
champion time and time and time again
agree and then suddenly comes a rise of
a kid from Norway right and another
force of nature and who would have
thought you're gonna go to Norway now to
go find Supreme chest oh no I mean it's
the needle in the haystack right so
toilet gate for all of its fanciful
dress did one thing that was very very
important for a modern age Maurice and
that was it did unify the world of chess
and when the rise of Vichy in Mexico
where he wins the world title
with the tournament format the double
round-robin then and bong he wins a
match just a heads up match against
Vladimir Kramnik and he's the guy he's
dama dama dominates the man and then
finally he he now becomes a world
champion but a different kind of world
champion than the world champions we
want and we like we want dominant world
champions we want world champions who
win matches who win tournaments who win
blitz who win everything and this she
wasn't that world champion Vichy began
became the guy who concentrated on
winning the million dollar matches he
gets sack and there in tournaments there
in tournaments and he says look
bring me my challenger and bring me a
million dollar world championship match
title and while he was playing his match
thing and winning the matches there was
a kid from
whay who became number one in the world
well he wasn't watching so much magnus
carlsen who didn't surprise people so
much given that when he was 12 or 13 he
was already a grandmaster at 13 and he
also played Karpov and beat Karpov head
to head it was a rapid yeah a game in I
think it was Iceland it may not Iceland
maybe was I almost be Gary Gary not yet
and it was so cute watching this kid
playing Gary
Gary's all intense like this oh right
right right and Magnus is like what's
happening on the other board yeah
where's my teddy bear too little
teenager and and he's a monster and it's
clear and Gary saw it and everybody saw
it
that he was coming and he was gonna be
coming on strong right and he proved it
when in 2010 it becomes number right in
the world rankings number one ever yeah
and for me I don't say Magnus as a child
of the computer and Internet and nothing
like that I say thanks to the Internet
this is very very important you know we
now have access to all of the files
together before it was the Soviets had
you know their databases and they're
locked away in the Moscow central chess
club archives and therefore Soviet
players only you and I man and you know
we'd no matter my or any kind of money
we couldn't get in there now the
internet was the great equalizer
there was Magnus coming from a country
Norway that has no proud history of
chess none they had tournaments a had
Norwegian Championships but come on it
was a virtual wasteland compared to the
talent that Magnus Carlsen came from I
mean here suddenly you know this tiny
tiny country relatively speaking in
population five million persons great
dominant force in skiing skiing
competitions I'm betting on the
Norwegian guy in chess competitions I'm
betting on the Russian kid Magnus
Carlsen appears and he also had so much
talent his memory is phenomenal he can
remember everything it seems they looked
at games you could just reference and
he'll
he's right there scary shows how chest
telling girls so then he gets to play
against and on right and you and I saw
something special here in st. Louis
that's right just before he goes to play
a nun
we've got electrocuted the see feel Cup
yep he's playing if he draws a game
against Levon Aronian he's the winner
wins the tournament 70k in his pocket
right
Ronia offers him a draw that's right
audiences do we say yes and it's over
and he doesn't even have a better
position no fact down upon at the time
right I don't think I can lose this
position I'd like to have a little fun
in play and you an are like what right
you wouldn't the whole thing the whole
money that showed something special
about this gym absolutely a hundred
percent that was an electrocuting moment
for both of us and I think I haven't
fully recovered from it if I were quite
frankly because the whole point in
sporting competition is one thing
victory you want to win that's it that's
and and and and if you have to win ugly
you went ugh Lee but it's about victory
and here victory was being offered and
this young man magnus carlsen said no I
want to play for a win great confidence
great stuff unbelievable and we expected
him to transfer to take that into into
the World Championship match but the
first three games in that magic later he
was shaky no question real shaky but
then he calmed down a steam room exactly
he reverted to this incredible
combination of abilities that he has the
board this positional grinding tactical
awareness is great tactical awareness
this ability to you know look into your
head and say you're not completely
comfortable over here are you well let
me just give you a little sore point as
a reminder over there and you don't like
it when this happens over here so I'm
gonna do I'm gonna ramp it up
over here and I'm gonna put you on the
defensive I mean the guy really any
wheels without a loss he also showed
that any position he was willing to play
to the very end the incredible desire to
play every game any percent he could
squeeze out of the position he would
play for and then he wins this match in
dominating style he jumps into a pool
that all his to celebrate and I think
everybody was joyous that we had this
young champion who was plated and I'm
one player in the world as well he
defends his match not by the same margin
of dominance against the same Anand yeah
but still showed that the true champion
had arrived and also the highest rated
player of all time the only question for
him is can he keep it up and be the
greatest player ever only time will tell
you